[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sky one portail fournit des produits et
des services axés autour des usages des
technologies immersives a été augmentée
à été virtuel a été mixte pour le compte
de clients industriels ou
essentiellement pour les professionnels
on agit en réponse à des besoins très
spécifiques sur le demande de nos
clients
mais on a aussi des solutions sur
l'étagère qu'on déploie pour certains de
nos clients
à l'époque du premier confinement s'est
tous retrouvé un peu de jours au
lendemain chez nous il se trouve qu'on
avait une solution sur les
professionnels du divertissement et qui
permettait d'utiliser des casseurs
étaient virtuels léger autonome en
réseau donc en fait on a pris cette
technologie la pure la développer pour
en faire une espèce de salles de réunion
virtuelle
le principe de cette solution en fait
c'est que chaque utilisateur se
choisissait son avatar on sera en
trouvaient tous dans un bureau virtuel
et on a tenu comme ça des réunions un
petit peu déjà pour travailler un peu
l'activité de la société comment on
s'organise parce qu'on a quand même été
obligé de ne pas marre et orienter nos
activités sa part mis pas mal de
phosphorer en fait sur tous ces sujets
en rouge et en retrouvant une
interaction assez naturel 1 ou ce qu'on
a constaté au moins à notre niveau c'est
que les usages des technologies merci
donc de plus en plus personnalisés donc
on va avoir vraiment des solutions qui
vont permettre à base un simple
smartphone une paire de lunettes de
réalité augmentée de vraiment bénéficié
d'augmenter son environnement de
discuter avec des personnes qui sont pas
là c'est quelque chose qui va vraiment
se généraliser à priori dans les
prochaines années
ces technologies là aussi permettent de
dans le secteur de l'événementiel nom du
spectacle commencé à mettre en oeuvre
d'une forme de disque alisation des
prestations pouvoir les diffuser
j'irai dans des conditions semi réel
mais virtuel à des personnes qui n'ont
pas forcément accès à ce spectacle donc
évidemment on parle du confinement où
les gens sont déjà restés chez eux mais
on parle aussi et ça c'est un des axes
auxquels on a travaillé avec le théâtre
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
pour les personnes qui n'ont pas accès
au théâtre on parle des personnes âgées
qui sont dans les ehpad
on parle des enfants malades notamment
c'est effectivement c'est aussi un des
axes de travail sur lequel on peut
avancer pour utiliser ces technologies
merci dans une optique de mieux
communiquer avoir plus d'expérience
sociale et artistique
[Musique]